[Musik]
sein leben ist ein einziges abenteuer
kaum ein winkel dieser welt den er nicht
bereist hat erstaunlichste begegnungen
prägten sein leben und nur knapp ist er
dem tod entronnen als er auf kannibalen
traf als fotograf hat er die größten
rockstars der 70er und 80er jahre
begleitet
[Musik]
er hat die modefotografie verändert und
eine der größten werbe ikonen kreiert
[Musik]
hannes schmid abenteurer fotograf
künstler und familienvater
[Musik]
spirit er hat einen unbändigen geist so
jemanden kann man nicht an ketten und
jetzt mit 70 jahren steht schmid vor
seiner größten herausforderung apple
kambodschas kinder retten
[Musik]
einige von ihnen wie sie klingt ist sehr
helle unter ernsten verhältnissen
aufgewachsen zog der toggenburger nach
seiner elektrikerlehre in die welt
hinaus und hat sich immer wieder neu
erfunden
das foto wird erklärt dass ich nicht
alles so ist das hilfswerk baue nicht
ich wäre so als ich lehre sein warum
eigentlich ins programm hilfen also
gerade jetzt
das bruchsichere günstig und thailand
das braucht man dazu nahmen ist es unser
fließen arbeit arbeit arbeit arbeit
arbeit arbeit und solange jeder weiß
gott
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
phnom penh am mekong kaum irgendwo ist
die schere zwischen arm und reich größer
als hier in kambodscha
es war vor sechs jahren wie schon oft
war schmid als fotograf in asien auf
reportage aber kambodscha ließ ihn
innehalten die armut und das elend der
bevölkerung haben ihn tief getroffen
schmidt ist in einem der zahlreichen
slums von phnom penh
gezielt will er ganze familien dort
rausholen
raus aus der stadt das ist seine vision
und was macht der ehemann hatte eine aus
gelenkt er kann fahren kann er in zug
fahren was uns das anschauen vielleicht
könnten wir sie aufnehmen schauen ob es
eine möglichkeit gibt
[Musik]
denn angeblich komplett
schmid ist auf dem weg zur familie der
in diese familie villa aus dem slum
holen und ihnen arbeit verschaffen
dafür hat schmid das hilfswerk smiling
gekko cambodia gegründet kein hilfswerk
im herkömmlichen sinne vielmehr diverse
unternehmen und start-ups
dazu gehört auch eine farm
bald wird diese familie dorthin ziehen
schmid ist ideenlieferant investor motor
und fundraiser aber alle projekte setzen
seine mitarbeiter in kambodscha und
parrot com einer der engsten mitarbeiter
von schmid erzählt dass die familie seit
15 jahren im slum lebt ich freue mich
sehr darauf weg zu gehen
wie geht es den kindern sehr gut sie
freuen sich
sie sagt dass sie den großeltern erzählt
haben dass sie in ein großes haus ziehen
werden aufs land und was nimmt sie mit
prinz etwas von hiermit auf die fahnen
nein wir haben nur unsere kleider dieser
slum heißt zement die menschen hier
kaufen auf den baustellen gebrauchte
lehre zum entwickeln
sie trennen sie auf und nahm aus den
einzelteilen große plastiksäcke für die
müllsammler kann die meisten familien da
jedes jedes geben was die regel nur das
herz sondern jedes bank da muss es als
baby jetzt da was hat das vögel
zurückkommen jetzt sagt sie sehen wie
vor mit dem ausschuss ein anschnitt ganz
dazu morgens hell bis dunkel wird
zwischen fünf und zehn dollar pro tag
kann eine familie so verdienen wenn das
geschäft gut läuft und wenn auch die
kinder arbeiten das gleiche typischen
wohne jetzt oder wanderten die zahlen
für seine hütte wird die das kann eine
tolle zweite bundesliga bis zur tür am
vortag
und wenn sie jetzt da stromanschluss
haben ist der strom zahlen und das land
das könnte meistens könnte das animierte
maschine ist aber acht an circa das
motto ohne vorwarnung und ausnahmefall
am liebsten würde schmid alle auf seine
farm mitnehmen aber sein hilfswerk ist
ein start up unternehmen kein
sozialdienst es geht einfach höchsten
die familie wo ja ein großer rucksack
mitgetragen
das sind natürlich rein machen sie haben
drogenproblem alkoholproblem sind den
gambler also mich verstehen und zu bauen
wir das natürlich stelle ich es
eigentlich schon no go wenn ihr könnt
das nicht haben ist in der fan community
und die probleme können händler die tus
in zwei tagen beginnt die familie dauern
ein neues leben und für die kinder
beginnt eine zukunft mit perspektiven
[Musik]
nicht weit vom zimmern slum entfernt die
müllhalde von phnom penh
einmal in kambodscha angekommen wollte
schmid wissen wo die ärmsten der armen
leben
so kam er auf die müllhalde und blieb
für viele monate wie die müllsammler
wohnte er in einer hütte
[Musik]
arminia egal ob man das was ich mache im
künstlerbereich ich mach alles genau so
ist bis mitte besinnen und dann la perla
parlament nötig denn im moment und muss
im internet aber laden lange eine sollen
dann muss man selber lieber will er
stand uns verstanden ist
erst als die müllhalde teil seines
eigenen lebens wurde hat schmid begonnen
zu fotografieren und zu filmen
[Musik]
ein fotograf auf der müllhalde
das hat der regierung nicht gepasst
das hat zuvor heftige führten das hat zu
nacht im krankenhaus oder aber der
richtige mann hat ein verbot kam mit mir
er hat ja eine frage darum ist das
jugendhaus villa oder hat ich sei so
lang sind hat auf den wird es für mich
dann hat er eigentlich so geschmunzelt
haben vermutlich 100 das geht aber nur
nachtigall will ich euch ein bisschen
500 dollar zahlen oder morgen
und er ist eigentlich eine sehr wohl
irgendwann einmal hat er den begriff vom
musikmachen regierung hat angst dass ich
kaká sie will dass ich das um schlachten
und seeds international in pfanne hauen
bis es dank merkt dann dass ich ja
eigentlich immer board half die luft weg
zu bringen
inzwischen ist filmen auf der müllhalde
verboten
wir drehen versteckt auf der rückseite
wo weniger menschen arbeiten und die
kontrollen der regierung seltener sind
diese familie verdient ihr geld mit
plastik recycling sie holen das plastik
vom müllberg waschen und trocknen es am
abend verkaufen sie es ein händler in
der stadt meist geht es dann weiter nach
vietnam wo granulat hergestellt wird und
von da nach china in die produktion
ich mache diese arbeit seit fünf jahren
wenn ich es schaffe genügend zu trocknen
und zu verkaufen sind es etwa 30 kilo
pro tag dafür bekomme ich ungefähr
30.000 real
das sind umgerechnet etwa 7 franken pro
tag
diese familie hat nicht einmal eine
richtige hütte
[Musik]
rund 70 prozent der bevölkerung leben
unter der armutsgrenze
die durchschnittliche lebenserwartung
liegt bei knapp 60 jahren
viele menschen treibt der hunger vom
land in die stadt
die meisten von ihnen sind analphabeten
ohne jegliche ausbildung sie stranden in
einem der zahlreichen slums
doch auch dort mangelt es ihnen an allem
[Musik]
es ist sechs uhr morgens die bewohner
dieser slums sind längst auf den beinen
sie bereiten essen zu dass sie später in
der stadt verkaufen
viele menschen hier arbeiten hart und
doch reicht es nirgends hin
ich behaupte es ist sogar dass sie
stehen dass man die menschen in not bild
das sich dem das mit
wir haben das auf die nächsten 25 jahren
hat das land ein großer wert nämlich die
billigste arbeitskräfte vor ganz asien
um das erreichte und die linie bilden
und sie erhalten also wie möglich dass
verständlichkeit bistro mit einer
vermutlich gewohnt schmid begann reis
und wasser zu verteilen
zahlte für die ausbildung der kinder
nachhaltig war das nicht
bald stand für ihn fest dass er
arbeitsplätze schaffen musste so würden
sich die familien selber ernähren können
und für die ausbildung ihrer kinder
aufkommen
[Musik]
knapp zwei autostunden nördlich von
kampen in der provinz cappuccino
aus dem nichts und innerhalb von nur
zweieinhalb jahren hat schmidt mit
seiner organisation eine farm community
aufgebaut
die familien stammen ausnahmslos alle
aus den slums seine familie kind war bin
ich bin ich dein papa
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
12 bauernbetriebe bilden die
fan-community die ehemaligen
slumbewohner bewirtschaften das land und
arbeiten in der hühner und schweinezucht
schmid ist kein landwirt und braucht
beratung für sein projekt viel know how
kommt aus der schweiz vom
landwirtschaftlichen bildungs und
beratungszentrum in hama vertrieben um
ihren flughafen hahn und diese wie
wichtig die erhaltung ist super nein
kein christ warum wollen und sie haben
den kontakt öffnung zum einer von den
vielen spezialisten schließen da hinten
alles abgefragt außerhalb davon
die sind einfach viel zu jung die sind
drüben sollen zwei mexikaner und die
handeln die haben mit denen und welle
will keine hand vermutlich meint da ist
eine zügige einigung ist ein anderer und
auf 3 bis 4
jetzt funktioniert sind 37 40 prozent
fruchtbarkeit von denen eine solche
episoden gab es zuhauf sie gedeihen die
tiere am besten was wächst auf diesem
boden seit jahrzehnten wurde hier nichts
mehr angebaut auf das wissen von
einheimischen konnte schmid nicht
zurückgreifen
die schreckensherrschaft der roten khmer
hatte dieses wissen komplett ausgelöscht
der anfang war hart und schmid erlebte
viele rückschläge eine fischzucht musste
er ganz einstellen
der boden musste erst fruchtbar gemacht
werden mühsam pixeln die arbeiter
pflanzen in die erde ein um nährstoffe
zu erzeugen ist natürlich das hoffen
ich war nicht das alles größer ich weiß
gar nicht wie ich hätte die bilder sind
fruchtbar wir gefühls das ist schwierig
ich also ich glaube dass ich vielleicht
ein anderes dank ich bin künstler und
das ist für mich das kunstwerk das ist
für mich irgendwo wirtschaftszone
sondern dass ich es künstlich erklärt
dies tanken und die fangen auch immer da
und dann entwickelt sich das ist unser
mini in die bildende kunst bühne
geschieht denn ich dagegen war nicht von
mir darunter entwickelt sich das und du
musst die offenheit hat die flexibilität
das ist doch schlussendlich ist wichtig
dass wir das resultat an und wichtig ist
dass es für die manche machbar
die bauernbetriebe sind klar auf
profitabilität ausgerichtet
alles was die familien für den staat
brauchen erhalten sie auf darlehens
basis inclusive betreuung und ausbildung
dann arbeiten sie auf eigene rechnung
sobald sie gewinn erwirtschaften
bezahlen sie eine pacht bald weil die
kooperative unabhängig von
spendengeldern funktionieren tarife
challenge ins musste man vorstellen
die familie jetzt von sigrid mit einer
billig und irgendwann kommen sie jetzt
und druck zu produzieren
dass ich eine heile welt jede taten und
ziele werde sie mit lehrerin die jetzt
vorangeht wichtig sei mehr zeit mit der
sie licht ins flagge sichern eindruck
dass sich der wald wo sie mir verdienen
also 77 jahren ist von der härteste
schule wo die jetzt oder machen
[Musik]
auch für die menschen aus den
umliegenden weilern gibt es viel arbeit
die fan-community wirkt sich auf die
ganze gegend aus ende woche ist zahltag
[Musik]
schmid arbeitet fieberhaft am ausbau
seines projektes auf dem areal baut er
gästehäuser und ein restaurant
der tourismus soll das ganze projekt
ankurbeln so klebten
ein junger jurist selbst in ärmsten
verhältnissen aufgewachsen hat durch ein
hilfswerk die chance auf eine ausbildung
bekommen
seit beginn also seit zweieinhalb jahren
ist er geschäftsführer von smiling gekko
cambodia roman kühn ein ehemaliger koch
aus der schweiz bildet während eines
monats unentgeltlich das restaurant
personal aus der gosse dollar
jeder der auf die farm kommt wird auch
geldspenden und unsere philosophie in
die welt hinaustragen es ist eine
riesige herausforderung menschen
auszubilden die nie zur schule gegangen
sind die nicht oder kaum lesen und
schreiben können
maria kann ich dir was zeigen bitte
halte deine hände so dann sind deine
finger geschützt kannst du das versuchen
zweimal zeige darüber zeigten vier mal
zeigen dass es hinter seines bruders
funktioniert für dieses projekt hat
schmidt inzwischen die hotelfachschule
in luzern an bord geholt
die schule schickt regelmäßig studenten
die im betrieb mithelfen und personal
ausbilden
die 26 jährige maria o nun die als
kleines kind verkauft wurde und nie zur
schule gegangen ist ist heute chef de
cuisine
restaurant und gästehäuser haben den
betrieb mittlerweile aufgenommen
aber damit noch lange nicht genug neben
den stallungen steht inzwischen eine
schreinerei geplant ist der bau einer
textilfabrik und mit der unterstützung
der eth und der pädagogischen hochschule
zürich soll hier schon bald eine schule
stehen das ist kapitalintensiv schmidt
braucht geld
70 jahre alt und noch so viel vor so
viel zu tun
schmid holt sponsoren an bord und
organisiert zusammen mit dem medienhaus
ringier das größte benefizkonzert dass
die schweiz je gesehen hat dies alles
nur mit einem kleinen verein im rücken
smiling gekko schweiz sind sieben leute
im vorstand und fünf im beirat alle
arbeiten ehrenamtlich
die künstler spielen gratis der gotthard
pegasus und 7
und das vorstellen dass wir heute ist
das natürlich gern ins internet oder
über hat es geschafft das haus stadien
durchfall und auf die anders darüber
denken aber da sagt oder einem die
antwort
[Musik]
die vorbereitungen für diesen event
haben vor monaten begonnen
schmid am open air rock gering in hinwil
mit dabei sind seine beiden kinder max
und anna
eigenhändig macht er werbung für sein
benefizkonzert
aber eigentlich ist er wegen etwas ganz
anderem dar
gleich wird er hier einen superstar
treffen den er aus längst vergangenen
zeiten kennt
[Musik]
konzerte bands rock n roll das war für
fast ein jahrzehnt das leben von hans
schmid hunderttausende von fotos zeugen
von dieser zeit unzählige stars hatte er
vor der kamera
schmid war nur ein besucher er
begleitete die bands wochen lang auf
ihren tourneen aber auch privat nicht
wenige nahm er mit in die schweiz zum
skifahren
[Musik]
die bands waren seine familie heute sind
diese fotos zeugen ihrer zeit und werden
als kunstwerke gehandelt
kaum jemand hat die wilden 70er und 80er
jahre der rock und popmusik so
eingefangen
die zeit von sex drugs and rock'n'roll
und sind sie für mich dass ich habe
diese schnupftabakdose schließt man die
augen zugehalten haben und dann sagen
sie sind alles wasser fließt das ist
schnee aus der schweiz dann hat und dann
hat das natürlich juckt 257 bands hat
schmidt fotografiert von der band
supertramp hat er die wohl wildesten
party bilder gemacht aber nur ein
einziges bild hat er veröffentlicht und
da waren alle noch angezogen
natürlich steigen die proben und yannick
weber wählen
aber nicht verkraftet haben habe ich bin
der beiden keine loyalität nicht hat zu
erinnern und dass ich das zeitlich nicht
ziemlich also ich kann immer ich hatte
sehr respektiert dass man mich als teil
vor ihrer familie gemacht
schmidt hätte mit solchen fotos viel
geld verdienen können aber profit money
sein antrieb und heute unterstützt im
murger hudson
ex supertramp er schenkt ihm seinen
welthit gibt little bit zur freien
verwendung für sein hilfswerk erzählte
mir von kambodscha ich wusste nichts
darüber und viele von euch
wahrscheinlich auch nicht aber da
herrscht eine unglaubliche armut und ein
großes elend singt alle mit mehr käfer
level bett vielleicht erreicht unsere
energie die armen leute in kambodscha
[Musik]
hier bewerben
ein paar stunden zuvor schmidt dreht mit
kindern aus der schule typen dorf einen
videoclip mit dem supertramp song für
sein hilfswerk mit dabei auch hier seine
beiden kinder ihre geburt sagt schmid
habe ihn verändert seit der vater ist
villa etwas bewirken sich hinkel zu
meiner art unseren herrn brach sie haben
doch was anziehen auf 18 grad
sie haben doch bildung medizinische ist
natürlich zu gewöhnlich ist bei unseren
tracht
und ich frage mich immer wieso ich das
nur sollte war dass mir wirklich
hunderte von millionen von kindern wo
man eigentlich die ganze team endeavour
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war
da hat ein großes herz
das menü genau das aber die menschen
können
was ist so niedrig ein
ist das schön dass ich das mit ihm an
namen wie max keiner lange jahre
panik sei derzeit das ist wie 27
niederlage und daher mit vielen vielen
dank das war nicht so berührt ich war zu
tränen gerührt
ich habe es versucht die menschen die du
berührst können sich glücklich schätzen
du hast die freude am geben und haben
sich kümmern entdeckt je mehr dir das
leben gibt desto mehr solltest du
zurückgeben wenn man das nur in der
schule lernen würde ich habe ihnen die
müllhalde und die slums gezeigt dann
habt ihr die andere seite des lebens
gesehen
[Musik]
ich verändere mich nicht da bin
ich hatte schnell ab die reise von
kontinent zu kontinent monatlich hin und
herren und herr und um mich kümmern und
ich bin wahnsinnig schnell in ihre
gedankenwelt und was man da in der nacht
verarbeiten das ist dass ich enorm mit
der stille die hilfe für mich wie
meditation und das ist mir nichts weil
das ist sicher ein schwerer kinos und
theater bin ich
fast ja ich muss und ich komme dann habe
ich da ihnen und dann wollte ich keine
andere mechanische messgrößen mehr von
dem die schienen rollen innen und ich
gebe mich neu trainieren und deine welt
an
denken in die gedanken wie die zehn
herren dürfen und aber nun hinterfragt
wieder alles um die zukunft der
mitarbeiter und haben wir dazu und auch
immer wieder zurückgehen ein anders
thema und darum sind die er nach der
stunde
diese nie langweilig sondern sie sind
sie selber flug und sehr sehr wie
haltiger gedanken
[Musik]
der cowboy ist heute eine werbe-ikone
allgemeingut für schmid anlass ihn neu
zu interpretieren der band seiner
eigenen fotografien auf leinwand auf dem
ölbild wird der cowboy wieder zum unikat
und wandert von der plakatwand ins
museum
manche bilder werden für über eine halbe
million franken gehandelt
aber schmid hat viel eigenes geld in
sein hilfswerk gesteckt er muss sich
dringend auf dem kunstmarkt zurückmelden
um sein neuestes werk zu zeigen tusche
auf papier organisiert er eine
ausstellung in seinem atelier in
deggendorf
ja du musst dich schafe reißen ihm
wahrlich niemand fertig ist möglich
zurück
natürlich merkt dass die stimme hat rund
um bugs
jetzt hat er sie wusste kunst
zurückzogen und der markt nur noch das
hilfswerk und vielleicht manchmal hinter
indiziere mich so mit dem hilfswerk und
das ist trust schlag sie eine
vierstellige und sagte hallo ich bin
schon als künstler also ganze das
toggenburg schmitz heimat
unter ernsten verhältnissen wuchs er auf
war oft als geist ein bub unterwegs bis
er schwer an tuberkulose erkrankte
sanatorium
das heißt wie arielle juni steht die
monat einmal ein besuch und das hat
einträgt
ich glaube sie wahnsinnig bka hat
ansicht kommen die eltern am in die
geschichte und das ist für mich ganz
wichtig sie ausrichten der mitte der
80er jahre das elternhaus
sohn hannes damals pausenlos in der
ganzen welt unterwegs kam so oft es ging
nach hause
als kind fuhr er häufig mit seiner
mutter auf dem markt
was ich bin ein großer teil familie
kindheit bin ich offen mehr tiefgang
sein eigentlich mini anderem rad fahren
kann und über den mittag ist die
katalyse mittags fertig machen und
eigentlich will ich so ein herziges in
hand dann natürlich die bude von hypnose
über die obwohl systembruch tampe mirka
auftritten der üblichen oder das ist
natürlich für mich ich hatte glaube so
nach der elektrikerlehre wanderte schmid
nach südafrika aus und begann zu
fotografieren
die kramer die neutrale ich benehme sich
matt bellamy schweizer elektriker
sondern ich bin fotograf und das ist
natürlich an dass sie da nicht eine
lösung parat
je größer das objektiv ist umso
wichtiger über interessieren die größte
wurden waren zweifel der apparat nicht
sowieso eine status superprofi taxiert
und das hat mich fasziniert dass das
unter schwindel schlüsselgewalt während
fast sieben jahren blieb er auf reisen
eine der prägendsten begegnungen war
jene mit dem stamm der dani und lani
rituelle cannibal des morgens vor mir
standen bereit
große ganze sie haben auf mich
geschossen
wenn wir wieder schulter rebstöcke kam
es zum schlager mit streiks habe ich
verprügelt und dann hans mit ins aus
stahl integriert mit dem dorf innen und
das hat er zu dem ritual gehört
natürlich dass sie rituale kannibalismus
lagert das heißt sie tötet mancher mit
will sie der wand jetzt also in erics
rechte brücke sondern das ist das
zeichen dass man sie grüne dem krampf
dass die person investieren denn im
neuen stall ablehnung
das ist für mich natürlich auch für die
jungs klossek sie will ich bin kein
krieg sehe ich bin ich ein feigling
seiner partner hat wie das ich
eigentlich
das ist es stinkt sie sagen ich
überhaupt einfach nicht zu eigen
als schmied in die schweiz zurückkehrte
jagte eine station die nächste rock
stars mode fotografie werbung reportagen
und vieles mehr
[Musik]
alle paar jahre erfand sich schmid neu
veränderte sein betätigungsfeld komplett
und nahm dabei einen immer reicheren
erfahrungsschatz mit aber immer blieb
schmid seiner heimat dem toggenburg
verbunden
[Musik]
klettern und skifahren der 13 jährige
max teilt die leidenschaft für den sport
mit dem vater
[Musik]
dabei sehe ich genau auf die zuvor lange
zeit
erst mit 52 jahren hat schmid geheiratet
mit 55 wurde er vater
[Musik]
blutjunge verbrannt dass ich das brutale
sich viele in der maschine die vordere
gefühl sein wenn ich etwas anstecken
persönlichkeit strecke bringt endlich
alle wichtigen hatte freitag dem
saudischen fällt auf was brüchig prägt
wie so glücklich ferien
ich brauche café evtl das buch ist
sicher bist ich physisch ausschließlich
vorstellen aber dir gar nicht von dem
weg ich wollte dem netten flüchten im
gegenteil ich aus gefühl militär aus
gefühl ich muss die these die letzte
minute stimmung um mir zu verwirklich
staaten das ist ein fakt also wenig
scharf zurück das ist und dann schauen
sie schon wieder erledigt und ich habe
mir eine familie mit kindern
das ist sommer energie ball
zusammenarbeit das ist beschwerlich ist
um ihr anteil ist dann entschieden bei
mir waren und mit den august die
buchungen eigentlich das weil deswegen
und wir können eine freie wahl aus
prinzip verbringen mehr zusammen also
wann ist der handelsertrag wird und wann
immer nötig und ich bin natürlich schon
die harmonika für fast unerträglich
gigantischer bull und nick sind wohl
nicht an also das gilt mich dann zu
machen sich nicht an landeskirchen haben
im südstaat erreicht wurden und jetzt
für mich habe ich das einfach nicht so
wichtig sicher künstlich sehr kreativ
hillary und hannes schmid sind seit 18
jahren verheiratet
niemand hatte so lange mit ihm
ausgehalten wie die chinesen aus
singapur
udo klos ich denke immer ich hab dich
gern bei mir also wenn es ein traum ist
deine leidenschaft tango wir müssen
unsere leben in vollen zügen leben so
wie wir es wollen hunderten von seinen
zielen zurückhaltend
er hat sowieso einen unbändigen geist so
jemanden kannst du nicht an ketten
ich sage ihnen immer du hast die energie
von 100 leuten
ich habe etwa die hälfte dieser energie
ich kann da nicht hinterherrennen
ich werde müde und ich finde wenn du so
eine energie hast dann konzentriere dich
auf etwas gutes so volles etwas was du
wirklich tun willst
[Musik]
als kleiner junge hatte auf dem markt
gelernt immer menschen in den bann zieht
heute steht hannes schmid vor 10.000
leuten im zürcher hallenstadion und
bringt seine botschaft aus kambodscha zu
den menschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
maurer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ok jetzt das feedback von denen heute
schon gar nicht negativ sind alle sind
positiv
[Musik]
ja das ist vielleicht die zum teil ein
großer teil von ihnen ohne das andere
eben das verständnis kann
das ist eigentlich das was ich zu
überholen oder weiß dass das zum teil
von ihnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin stolz
wie ein dunkler schatten liegt die
schreckensherrschaft der roten khmer
über kambodscha
mitte der 70er jahre wurden über zwei
millionen menschen gefoltert und
ermordet
die gesamte intelligenz des landes wurde
ausgelöscht
die armut auf dem land ist erdrückend
seit ihrer kindheit wohnte wann hier im
wald ab und zu kann sie etwas holz
verkaufen und versucht sich und ihre
drei kinder so durchzubringen
der vater kümmert sich nicht um die
familie eine baufällige hütte als küche
und wohnraum eine kleine hütte als
schlafplatz im wald sammelt sie mit
ihren kindern bären frösche oder
schlangen um zu überleben
brehm der älteste ist elf jahre alt war
das baby ein ja und fanny ist 5 das baby
ist hier geboren
bei der geburt war ich alleine
es ist krank wir waren einmal beim arzt
es wurde geimpft der arzt hat gesagt es
sei unterernährt
ich würde wieder zum arzt gehen wenn ich
geld hätte aber das geht nicht im moment
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
schmid ist weit gereist hat viel elend
und armut gesehen
in kambodscha konnte er nicht mehr
wegschauen das mitdenken hoffen die
genossen von den roten khmer bis zum
heutigen tag geplant
ich begriff dass hübner das wendet dann
meinen kram not vietnamesen oder
chinesen notlanden irgendwo im finger
gerührt hat für office wo sie mit
beteiligung sie sind und ich glaube es
geht wirklich kreis anders langlauf der
weiß wo so brutal durchgeschüttelt
worden ist und sonntagmorgen und
schlachte wohne ich mit kambodscha und
ich finde wir sind das den menschen
schuldig das ist ein teil auf äußere
frankfurt ist ein teil wurde
verantwortlich von der weltgemeinschaft
wie sowieso setzte sich david die
spendengelder von smiling fließen unter
anderem in das tuk tuk projekt so kubon
ist hier der chef
einmal im monat kommen die fahrer zur
inspektion
ähnlich wie die familien auf der farm
werden die fahrer sorgfältig rekrutiert
das finde ich sehr hübsch das gefällt
mir
es wäre gut wenn man das bei jedem topf
installieren könnte ich will keine
vorhänge aber das ist sehr wirksam gegen
diebstahl ist das sehr schön ist das ist
ein geschenk eine spende
aber du kannst es nicht mehr sehen
das ist vom tisch das ist unsere
visitenkarte
das muss aber frisch und hübsch aussieht
das ist dein job
versteh mich nicht falsch das ist kein
problem wenn es einmal vorkommt
und noch immer macht schmid genau das
womit er ganz am anfang auf der
müllhalde begonnen hat überlebenshilfe
[Musik]
hiroko fujii der messias ist eher so
dass ich aber tradition von der analysen
zeigen also jetzt ein ich fühle mich
jetzt befinde
achim - minimum von monika und mir
halfen mit dem wechsel die was man
verteilen eigentlich nicht groß jetzt
jede gesamtsituation von anderen länder
einfach ihnen spd betonieren plastik
dass die kinder wirklich eine tochter
bist du jetzt eigentlich nicht auch ihre
handlanger von der regierung für die
regierung okay der hells angels als
hilfswerk da jetzt der hannes schmid die
übernahme des offerings bestimmt also da
muss man sich fragen wie haben sie die
von hilfswerken haben und ich würde mir
eigentlich wünschen dass mir neues augen
zusammen tour und dann könnte mir zum
president und sagen wenn du jetzt nicht
das unterstütze ich das gremium das land
wird starb liebenden welche schulen zum
beispiel teile und die anders hätte ich
es keine entschuldigung genügt in
brackley kitzler hier länger nur darum
so lange begriffen wie wichtig die hilfe
wird da sowohl alle lügen in aluminium
mache das was mir und trotzdem braucht
immer minar stoß und dass ich im moment
mini und mini große belastung und ich
haben über los geht's am montag machen
weniger oder jetzt also nicht nach
sondern es wird eigentlich ebene druck
mit einer größe
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jesus
heute bezieht familie dauern aus dem
zement slum ihr neues zuhause
es ist die zwölfte und vorläufig letzte
familie
[Gelächter]
alles was die achtköpfige familie
mitbringt hat in einem kleinen sack
platz
eco ist sehr glücklich sie hier
willkommen zu heißen ich hoffe den
kindern gefällt es und ihnen auch in den
nächsten tagen haben sie zeit sich
einzuleben verriet kennen sie ja er
kommt jede woche her wenn etwas ist
können sie das mit ihm besprechen
vielen dank und viel glück
[Musik]
wir sind sehr glücklich und froh an
diesen neuen ort zu leben
es ist wie im himmel wir werden jetzt
viel lernen müssen von den angestellten
und von unseren nachbarn
[Musik]
die